[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mardi 13
novembre
en 1914 un violoncelliste est mobilisée
comme brancardier il part au front avec
son instrument qui va transmettre
l'histoire du conflit l'histoire dans
les tranchées la compagnie périphériques
joue à la ferme de bel ébat leur point
commun ils ont tous été junior chez
déclic théâtre devenu professionnel ces
comédiens se retrouvent pour une soirée
la quatrième édition du trappeur
profamille quatrième édition aussi pour
le festival de la bande annonce de bois
d'arcy cette année la ville met à
l'honneur en lino ventura une soirée
placée sous le signe du cinéma et animé
par vincent perrot
les commémorations de la grande guerre
continue la ferme de bel ébat de
guyancourt propose le violoncelle poilus
l'histoire vraie d'un musicien célèbre
mis en scène par la compagnie
périphériques
marylène iapichino l'enfer des tranchées
racontée par un violoncelle en 1914 le
célèbre violoncelliste maurice maréchal
est mobilisée comme brancardier
il amène avec lui son instrument pour
apporter un peu de musique ofrou
évidemment je n'en sais rien n'a pas n'a
pas la larme n'a pas les armes n'a pas
le napalm
la conscience de l'homme il a un certain
recul vis-à-vis de ce qui s'y passe donc
c'est comme un enfant et donc il ya de
l'innocence et forcément il ya de
l'espoir
une histoire vraie racontée par hervé
mais seront dans une nouvelle en 2014
pour la pièce les musiciens ont leur
place sur scène en accompagnement du
texte
on est un peu là comme des acteurs pad
pas des acteurs au même titre que que le
comédien qui joue le rôle du violoncelle
mais et on a une pas on est vraiment
intégré dans le dans le spectacle comme
la lumière d'ailleurs fait aussi partie
de ce spectacle c'est ce violoncelle
poilus qui raconte sa grande guerre et
sa relation avec ses musiciens
c'est comme un comédien dans une
compagnie en vie des histoires avec les
autres parfums se sont délaissés on se
dit mais pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
m'emmènent là bas moi je voudrais aller
là bas et les histoires des jalousies
dans les compagnies tout ça j'ai
considéré de violoncelle comme ammann
artistes avec tout ce que ça implique
s'éternise lacroix jouer
le spectacle s'adapte à toute la famille
pour une histoire de la grande guerre
d'un point de vue original à guyancourt
toujours de la musique et de la poésie
depuis 2011 les itinéraires poétique
faut entendre les voix des femmes et des
hommes
censuré dans leur pays une soirée leur
est consacrée à la batterie ce jeudi 15
novembre il y à 25 ans déclic théâtre
été fondé la troupe a depuis vu un grand
nombre de ces comédiens devenir
professionnel et depuis quatre ans la
grande famille se réunit trappe un
profane lycée ce vendredi 16 novembre
antoine rabot soir soit vous êtes l un
des comédiens de la compagnie est ce que
pour ce rendez vous se prépare
spécifiquement toujours un peu way
toujours un peu parce que il ya des il
ya des grands noms des juniors de
trappes qui ont marqué la compagne en
tout cas qu'ils reviennent nous faire
l'honneur de jouer avec nous et
d'essayer de faire passer une bonne
soirée
autre à pister derrière aux habitants de
de partout qui vont venir nous voir
et ouais c'est tout il ya toujours une
petite pression particulière pour ce
genre d'événement salah meurice et une
énorme salle est ce que la tante du
public aussi est tellement forte en se
disant c'est les anciens ce qu'ont déjà
une carrière conformer eux mêmes les
juniors actuelle way we will ont une
attente forcément après je pense
ils vont pas être déçus parce que là on
a vraiment des on avait des vieux de la
vieille des plus jeunes des plus jeunes
de la génération plus récente de juniors
en tout cas qui qui sont sortis on se
connaît tous très bien puis surtout on a
on a vécu les mêmes choses dans cette
équipe qui a formé beaucoup de gens et
qui a construit beaucoup de jeunes en
fait tout simplement dont je fais partie
des rôles a dit junior c'est le mot
parce que cette année c'est le junior
all star alors qu'ils sont des judas les
juniors déjà à déclic c'est de manière
générale c'est une catégorie c'est une
parole les juniors ça correspond déjà
une tranche d'âge dans un premier temps
donc c'est l'âge du lycée donc c'est les
16-19 ans mais c'est à déclic théâtre
c'est aussi ce qu'ont ce qu'on peut
appeler une équipe d'excellence en fait
on a la chance d'avoir un gros vivier
grâce à l'activité assez conséquente de
déclic théâtre qui nous permet de
trouver des profils et de sélectionner
des profils de jeunes qui qui peuvent
créer un beau collectif qui marche bien
et du coup ça donne en général de bons
résultats et donc les juniors enfin les
anciens juniors qui seront sur scène le
16 novembre sont passés par cette
catégorie sont devenus professionnels
oui oui pour la plupart bâgé cette
histoire aussi j'ai cette histoire aussi
et c'est ça qui
c'est un énorme cadeau que le déclic
théâtre a dès maintenant et je pense des
centaines de jeunes alors d'autres ont
arrêté avant les juniors d'autres juste
après d'autres ont continué parce que
pour certains ça les a lancés dans une
carrière d'autres ça les a aidés pour
l'heure notre carrière professionnelle
bien sûr il ya toujours un intérêt enfin
un attrait danse danse et juniors la
confiance ya toujours un intérêt à la
famille se sentir et ce sans se sentir
valorisé dans un collectif c'est
toujours bon pour l'estimé de soi pour
pour savoir où on en est et puis je
pense que je suis même convaincu que
déclic théâtre
cette force et cette faculté de donner
des belles valeurs aux jeunes ce qui
permet de les voir grandir de manière
assez assez sympa franchement ça vous
l'avez dit vous avez été junior vos
souvenirs justement de cette période de
laisser l bike pour facile l'adolescence
qu'est ce que ça vous a apporté vous
personnellement
bah c'était le seul endroit on me disait
que j'étais bon déjà donc c'est déjà
énorme
non ce que ça m'a apporté ces des amis
que j'aurais jamais rencontrés sans ça
deux cultures différentes d'origines
différentes
ceux de milieux sociaux différents il
rien qu'il nous en qui qui nous
rassemblait à part cette discipline et
dans les plus gros souvenir c'est les
séjours
on a la chance de pouvoir partir en
tournée faire des séjours avec les
jeunes
tu vois c'est avec les coachs j'avais
moi je m'en souviens très bien il sadoum
bia et n'aurait yakine louise qui qui
nous accompagnait on se marre énormément
et on faisait beaucoup d'impro c'était
c'était passionnant issa doumbia lui
n'est pas prévue le 16 novembre mais
vous faites partie de l'équipe des verts
est avec vous il ya laurie père et
caroline marc julie gilbert mathieu de
l'âge est incertain papy oui on est
vraiment monté encore oui il ya certains
papiers je sais et donc forcément c'est
un honneur de jouer avec des noms comme
ça
parce que là c'est que des noms qui
résonnent dans milieu de l'improvisation
leur hyper et elle a maintenant une
carrière montante qui mérite tout ça la
marque est aussi des kits théâtre par
son histoire et son caractère et
papilles tout ce qu'il a tout ce qu'il a
fait pour la ville de trappes saint
quentin et pour nous surtout mais en
face il ya aussi cédric et gain qui
vient directement du québec qui est dans
une des plus grosses ligues du québec et
qui est un énorme joueur qui faisait
partie de la première génération de
juniors de trappes et oui c'est des
honneurs c'est un honneur de jouer avec
des noms comme ça forcément juste et
rose allait nommer un peu dans l'équipe
rosiers aussi on dit puis mort crois
qu'on connaît bien sûr saint quentin
davies ça va être compliqué de les
battre est ce qu'on prend des petites
notes en avoir les spectacles que
certains ont fait on échange
j'essaie de trouver des petites au même
pas besoin de les étudier on les connaît
trop bien mais non on va surtout le tout
c'est de s'amuser de mettre le spectacle
en avant et cette discipline qui qui est
quand même
on a quand même la chance d'avoir à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la capitale de
l'impro en france qui est rap et qui
maintenant déborde sur toutes les
communes aux alentours donc ouais non je
pense qu'il faut surtout qu'on se
concentre à offrir un superbe spectacle
aux gens qui se sont déplacés en plus on
a la chance d'être d'être complet ça ça
fait ça fait du bien ça fait du bien et
ça fait plaisir c'est ce qui fait la
force de l'impro c'est pas seulement les
comédiens c'est tout ce qu'il ya autour
même si les arbitres les musiciens c'est
vivant - le gros groupe
oui c'est un gros groupe qui qui tient
vrai qu'ils tiennent vraiment le rythme
du spectacle c'est eux c'est le
squelette donc si on doit expliquer les
choses c'est la partie qui est non
improvisé pour que nous on puisse en
profiter dans les meilleures conditions
il doit y avoir un cadre très très bien
rodée et pour ça on est très bien équipé
c'est super bien entouré on le sent dans
vos paroles trappe
impro famine et c'est une famille déclic
25 ans une famille ouais ouais c'est une
famille parce que
de par leur principe de formation moi
j'ai commencé au collège effet le cursus
le plus classique à déclic j'ai commencé
au collège j'étais pris dans les juniors
on m'a formé à intervenir dans les
collèges
j'ai moi-même former des collèges
étaient ensuite coach des juniors et
ainsi de suite donc c'est une compagnie
qui a mené qu'à grossir et donc il ya en
tout cas à voir et à former des jeunes
qui viennent de partout et qui sont
passionnés en tout cas part ça donc ça
c'est c'est plutôt très bien vous avez
la fuite au fond un succès jusque dans
les places vendues c'est complet conflit
encore une petite chance
oui il ya une petite chance il ya une
petite chance il ya une petite chance
parce qu'un jeu concours qui est
organisé par l'émission l'antisèche sur
mammites marmite fm est en fait il
suffit pour jouer il suffit de l'icc et
de tags et une personne avec qui vous
voulez aller voir le train pas pro
family est donc en message privé faut
mettre trappe un pro familia est à 4
plus votre numéro et il y aura un tirage
au sort et du coup on offrira les six
dernières places pour venir voir ce
spectacle aux amateurs faut être à
droite rapide ouais merci antoine rabot
à la boucherie des verts ou des roses va
l'emporter
réponse vendredi 16 novembre à 20h30 à
la merise de trappes
on va pas loin juste à côté l'encours
après 18 mois de travaux
l'école de musique de la ville a ouvert
ses portes des travaux notamment porté
sur l'acoustique des salles mais aussi
sur la luminosité grâce à un puits de
lumière
le 5 novembre dernier les élèves et
professeurs ont investi ses nouveaux
locaux dans le quartier des sept manches
on a voulu garder le côté historique de
ce bâtiment qui je le rappelle était un
centre comme unique et qu'on a voulu
donc transformée en une école de musique
un bâtiment 100% dédié donc à la musique
à l'apprentissage de la musique
l'expression il ya treize salles plus
donc un une partie donc auditorium pour
pouvoir faire des représentations 900 m²
dédié au bâtiment mort accidentellement
en 1917 antonio de la gandara était un
ami de versailles
celui qui fréquentaient les salons
mondains de la capitale trouvait dans la
cité royale sérénité et inspiration le
musée lambinet lui consacre sa première
rétrospective
images sont signés michael almy d'euros
son décès la plongée dans l'oubli
antonio de la gandara disparaît en 1917
et laisse derrière lui des centaines
d'oeuvres ses descendants en expose 120
aujourd'hui au musée lambinet un travail
de vingt ans de recherches
tout ça ça a donné lieu à la rédaction
d'un ouvrage biographique en 2011 et
depuis 2011
en fait nous avons tous chercher les uns
les autres
un musée susceptibles d'accueillir
l'exposition rétrospective qui est elle
un petit peu le la chose nécessaire pour
que l'artiste revienne en pleine lumière
quelle belle artiste et quel dommage que
les musées ne l'est pas mis davantage en
valeur ces dernières années et comme il
y à un regain aujourd'hui de belles
époques un petit peu partout tant dans
le mobilier que dans l'expression
artistique de peinture notamment
on pense que la gandara toute sa place
aujourd'hui aux côtés de des bolides et
jacques emile blanche
antonio de la gandara débute par le
portrait à montmartre et dans les salons
mondains des portraits répartis dans les
huit salles du musée versailles et le
contraindre à y avait un lien avec
versailles parce qu'elle fréquentait
long tail
réservoir la ville il la découvre en
1885 lors d'une rencontre avec robert de
montesquiou le peindre tombe amoureux du
parc et des jardins de versailles la
gandara à versailles il retrouvait un
peu de la sérénité qui lui manquait
lorsqu'il heures mais ces modèles en
pause continuelle avec les cancans qu'il
avait eu à subir et puis les caprices de
toutes ces dames
il trouvait donc dans le dans le concert
du jardin de versailles
des moments de repos plénitude qui lui
permettait en même temps d'exercer son
art celui qui connut la gloire de son
vivant retrouve un peu de sa superbe
plus de cent ans après son décès antonio
de la gandara revient à versailles le
château de versailles consacre un nouvel
espace à l'éducation artistique pour les
enfants des salles atelier spécialement
conçu pour de nombreuses animations
financé notamment grâce au mécénat de la
fondation bettencourt schueller
un reportage de marie line yapi chine gg
ça avec moi j'aimerais que tu est un
raciste à notre atelier si vous êtes
d'accord
un atelier théâtre autour des fables de
la fontaine dans la demeure du roi
soleil
vous allez imaginez que vous vous
promenez dans la forêt de versailles au
temps du roi louis xiv
grande nouveauté est d'habitude réservé
à l'hémicycle du congrès le château de
versailles offre souvenez du midi aux
enfants pour des ateliers art et
éducation
on a multiplié par quatre nos espaces on
a de nouveaux espaces qui ont offert 250
m² ont vraiment on va pouvoir offrir
quatre fois plus d'ateliers pour les
publics scolaires pour les publics
éloignés pour les familles des espaces
modulables au gré des différentes
activités proposées des plus physiques
comme le théâtre aux activités manuelles
comme la dorure et pour s'inspirer
une visite du château est prévu avant de
passer à la phase activités voile à
regarder ces autocollants d'accord donc
sur les tâches et puis tu peux le mettre
pour faire donc là la dentelle le bas de
la robe de la duchesse qu'on a une
visite à peu près qui dure une heure et
ils ont une heure d'atelier donc on
convient dans les salles d'ateliers et
là il crée en ayant poussé en
s'inspirant de tous les portraits qu'ils
ont vu les portraits en pied donc les
portraits d'apparat des rois lui 18
charles disent les enfants
s'enrichissent du château pour
développer leur créativité
la cptaq après je vais dessiner la robe
dessinée rome qu à papier après je vais
prendre ça je vais décorer cartoonesque
j'aime bien déjà à faire des démarches
la ch'ti
on s'amuse et chez bien l'espace art et
éducation est proposé au groupe scolaire
et associatif
sur réservation cinq ou six nouveaux
ateliers devraient voir le jour en 2010
9 et s'étendant petit à petit aux
familles des résumés des petits films
mais en art 1 part entière les
bandes-annonces quelques minutes de
vidéo pour nous donner envie d'aller
dans les salles de cinéma depuis quatre
ans ces bandes annonces sont au coeur du
festival de bois d'arcy jean-philippe
plus bonjour vous êtes le maire adjoint
de la commune en charge de la culture et
c'est donc la quatrième édition du
festival
elles sont peu dire que déjà c'est
devenu un rendez vous incontournable
abbas est clairement devenu un rendez
vous incontournable un vrai succès quand
on l'a lancée il ya il ya quatre ans on
se posait la question c'était une
nouveauté un pari est clairement ça
fonctionne les personnes attendent
maintenant les nouveautés les nouvelles
bandes annonces
c'est complet ce qui est un bon signe et
aussi donc c'est un vrai beau résultat
mais comment on en vient à dire on va
faire un festival de la bande annonce
parce que c'est souvent quelque chose
qu'on voit avant les films qu'on va les
voir pour donner envie mais de là à en
faire une soirée d'adieu on part de du
territoire si un seul sans valeur si on
a la chance d'avoir les d arcy du fil le
cnc on a tout un quartier qui est dédié
aux acteurs au présent exactement
et en fait on se dit comment est ce
qu'on peut changer un peu notre petit
culturel faire évoluer cette politique
culturelle tout en proposant quelque
chose de nouveau à travers le cinéma est
en fait c'est un art à part entière la
rédaction bande annonce et jusque là
savaient pas été traité comme on l'a
traité nous à travers parce que vincent
perrot présente vincent perrot le
présentateur l'animateur là la base
solide peut-être du festival c'est le
sait le coeur du projet on est ravis
qu'il ait accepté au tout début il ne
fait pas que présentée et animée y
contribue énormément au projet il
apporte lui même des bandes-annonces ils
structurent les séquences français c'est
le moteur du projet obtenant c'est
justement ça se prépare longtemps à
l'avancé demande même si ce n'est que
deux minutes il faut le regarder il faut
les analyser j'imagine combien de temps
ça prend on travail d'une année sur
l'autre
quand une à peine à peine le la soirée
terminée on fait on se laisse quand même
dix quinze jours pour ce soufflé un peu
mais après derrière clairement on part
sur ce qui a fonctionné et ce qui a
moins bien fonctionné et surtout ce
qu'on a envie de mettre à l'honneur la
saison d'après essayez de le coller le
plus possible à l'actualité et apporter
un peu plus d'interaction que le public
ce que chaque année il ya aussi un thème
un fil rouge à cette année pas des
moindres lino ventura lino ventura
grands acteurs français on est pile
entre le centenaire de sa naissance et
le trentenaire de sa de son décès de sa
disparition c'est l'année j'ai un peu
charnière il est à l'honneur à bonnart 6
depuis le début de l'année on a mis son
nom sur sur une maison des associations
dans le fameux quartier de la croix
bonnet et son fils laurent sera présent
et on aura des échanges avec lui et pour
décrypter les bandes-annonces de ses
principaux films et pas que les plus
connus loin de là ce que dans les
bandes-annonces on arrive déjà à
connaître à se rendre compte du talent
qui avait lino ventura oui clairement
on en parlait juste avant mais c'est
vrai que essayé de faire passer un
message à travers les bandes annonces et
un vrai sujet il lui il avait un talent
d'acteur où il était capable de rendre
captivant un film de vouloir faire venir
les gens alors on l'a dit vincent perrot
1 à la tête de l'équipe il ya beaucoup
de travail mais le public
il a aussi son mot à dire le public il a
son mot à dire exactement on va encore
fallu faire évoluer cela mais cette
année on a décidé de faire interagir de
plus en plus les spectateurs avec avec
vincent perrot et avec l'organisation où
il y aura des quizz d'organiser et des
prix des prix sont remises en mise en
jeu des places de spectacle et je pense
que dans les années à venir on ira
encore plus loin pour faire en effet
potentiellement une sélection en amont
des des bandes-annonces souhaité ça
restera sous la limite de trouver les
bandes-annonces de qualité mais en effet
ce fait si la vocation d'interagir le
plus possible avec les artisiens et les
personnes order doit dire si tu vas
venir parce que c'est clairement
maintenant devenu un festival
départemental où les mêmes régional des
quizz il faut donc révisé non il faut
pas révisé c'est mieux mais il faut il
faut pas révisé c'est surtout sur ce qui
va se passer dans la soirée et voir si
les perdants sont les personnes sont
attentives
et ça va être très sympathique comment
est-ce que vous expliquer un tel succès
ce qu'en plus c'est compliqué chaque
année mais les gens reviennent les gens
reviennent les gens reviennent pour
plusieurs raisons c'est une façon très
originale de traiter le cinéma et on
pourrait penser que deux heures et une
trentaine de bandes annonces ou quand on
a vu deux fois on en a on peut
potentiellement avoir marre et ben en
fait la façon dont est traité le
séquencement des partis et surtout si le
talent de vincent perrot fait qu'on
passe une soirée inoubliable et ça
explique un peu aussi l'histoire du
cinéma on voit l'évolution peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui on monte plus les scènes
d'action elle et pas que des scènes
d'émotion je ne sais pas il ya une vraie
évolution de la bande annonce je vais
pas donner tous les secrets mais on a de
plus en plus tendance à avoir des
bandes-annonces où tout est dit dans la
bande annonce et on est un peu déçu de
d'être au cinéma parfois et de se rendre
compte qu'on a déjà tout vu et puis
aussi cette année on a une petite
surprise puisqu'il ya un film qui s'est
tournée à bois d'arcy on a retrouvé la
bande annonce donc ça sera
l'introduction de la soirée ce sera un
beau monde sera découvrait on apparaît
du 17 novembre
en fait le festival se décompose en
plusieurs temps il ya 18 novembre ce que
le cinéma c'est aussi pour les enfants
exactement ce cette soirée du 18
novembre cette soirée du 17 novembre
principalement quand même plus orienté
pour les adultes il ya une déclinaison
juniors qui se fait le dimanche à 15h ou
là on présente l'angle un petit sous un
angle un peu différent on va surtout
présenter les bandes annonces des films
junior qui vont arriver dans les
prochains mois et on est en ce1 aussi
peut-être un peu plus pour les ados d'y
réfléchir avec le décès de stan lee
fière de ses de faire une toute petite
séquence sur les principaux martel qui
ont été faits c'est justement novembre
pour les enfants on approche de noël en
général les disney sort les pixar c'est
le timing parfait pour donner envie aux
enfants d'aller au cinéma on a un super
cinéma à bois d'arcy et 400 places dans
une situation incroyable un coin de la
grange est clairement avec les fêtes de
fin d'année les les films pour un junior
et pour enfants sont tous sortir donc
c'est un bon moment pour les faire venir
il reste que pour les petits reste de la
place pour les petits il reste de la
place
absolument proscrits on s'inscrit sur le
site de la ville tout et tout est
indiqué avec un questionnaire et on sera
très site de la ville
s'affichent à l'écran merci jean suivi
plus alors les bandes-annonces révèle
quelques uns de leurs secrets
c'est le samedi 17 novembre pour les
adultes le samedi le dimanche 18
novembre pour les enfants on passe
maintenant à notre agenda
[Musique]
il aura attendu plus de 30 ans pour être
interprété le livre de ma mère patrick
timsit partage son amour pour les
ouvrages d'albert cohen
aujourd'hui encore son livre de chevet
un seul en scène où il laisse parler
l'enfant qui sommeille en chacun de nous
il sera au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines du 20 au 22
novembre au centre alfred de vigny vous
pourrez découvrir un michelangelo merisi
dit le caravage
le peintre qui va révolutionner la
peinture italienne du xviie siècle une
conférence animée par claire de la
varenne le mardi 20 novembre
alain bernard donne des cours de musique
un peu particulier il fait découvrir les
coulisses de la musique ses premiers
courts ses compositions de musique de
film il joue à la verrière ce jeudi 15
novembre
[Musique]
le piano c'est l'instrument idéal pour
travailler
[Musique]
on imagine mal bernard hermann composant
les musiques d'hitchcock à la cornemuse
ou john williams composants star wars de
la flûte à bec à l'issue d'un concert un
chef d'orchestre de renommée
internationale est importunée par un
spectateur envahissant un intrus qui
devient peu un peu inquiétant fausse
note est en face à face opposant
christophe malavoy et tom novembre au
théâtre espace coluche de plaisir
regardez je suis désolé de vous déranger
m mais je ne pouvais pas quitter ce
festival sans vous avoir félicité merci
merci mon nom et les ondines qu'elle
avait qu'un seul l un léger sourire
peut-être moins carnassiers impeccable
ne pouvons plus qui est là les ondines
gueule qui joue au prisme d'elancourt
une comédie interprétée par andrea besco
eric métayer un duo entre une danseuse
professionnelle blessés et un
scientifique autistes extraits bonjour
allez vous faire fac de date à
date heure vous êtes prêts à démarrer
l'an
pas un des quatre volets quoi je vais
apprendre à danser
ah ouais d'où les poussins
c'est quoi tu descends dans la rue tu
croises en f1 tout faisait quoi c'est la
fin de ce set 8 culture merci de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi
prochain
[Musique]